I
I'm going to talk about some exploration
of buttons and just doing
myself I studied mathematics in Prague
and in Amsterdam worked as a researcher
consultant programmer and traveled a
little bit over the world and light with
some machine learning and some smart
algorithms and this is a project that I
actually started with a patent lawyer in
Hong Kong hum and so let's do some
exploration into buttons yeah so people
are ready innovative from from long time
ago already so they are coming field
very very interesting designs and they
are happy to actually profit with them
so they patent them so these are really
like very useful very useful innovations
that were patented already like more
than 100 years ago you can still find
them in in like Google database of
patents even you can find an artificial
snake there if you look hard okay so
this is one way to explore patents but
actually look more at the text side of
of natural language of how the patterns
are described so the outline of this
talk is first view I will start with
motivation behind this project then I
will describe what cuckoo is actually
needed to deal with this data then I
will introduce the workflow how to
actually build this semantic space using
topic modeling
and very very nice library Jensen and
finally I will conclude with some well
future future work or actually also like
current experimentations so the
motivation why patents so here you can
see the number of granted patents by
ground here and these are the United
States buttons so you can see that the
space is actually getting quite crowded
and unfortunately the system is quite
broken it's it's not dealing with the
with the innovation in the right way but
the buttons were actually designed or
well introduced to support innovation
but it seems like nowadays it's actually
more suffocating all the innovation so
we should look into this and actually
try to do something with it also I would
like to know is there any one of you who
actually filed a patent application who
actually has experience with this and I
always love to hear the divorce stories
actually from like engineers that had to
deal with the with the lawyers and all
the process so well the process is not
that simple unless you have actually
like some buffers in like big company
that that deals with this hidden video
lawyers so it's also slow and costly so
these are the negative reasons why to do
this project the positives are that the
data us united states patents and
trademarks office the data is freely
available they actually release the new
data every week and and the data is also
structured and it's mostly consistent
it's actually
the language is consistent over the
years and also it's a great chance to
learn something really interesting some
new technologies and basically explore
new new space for your smart algorithms
so data koo koo koo koo koo koo is a
Chinese term referring to any study
learning or practice that they require
requires patience energy and time to
compete complete and indeed dealing with
this data requires patient patience
energy and time to complete because the
data is even though it's structured and
its language is consistent it's not
ready to actually process by the natural
image processing tools so how does it
actually look like currently the data
are provided in XML format which is nice
but before that it was in the sgml like
key value store I was we will stream
much more difficult to deal with with
these text files also the big job we are
actually using the moment are from 1975
to present before that the patterns were
purely paper-based and even though they
are scanned and you see art they are not
actually very useful and it takes lots
of effort to actually get some useful
information from them for these almost
40 years the USPTO actually used eight
or probably more than eight different
formats of this for this data for the
schema and so we have to somehow treat
it the data has more than 70 gigabytes
and that's compressed and that's just
text we are not dealing with pictures
yet so it's not small and the data
consists of pattern grants and patent
applications so when I actually check
the data and dry well was asking how to
actually parse this it's a little bit
messy it's not clear how to how to
actually extract a useful information
from that so I had to actually study all
the xml formats and the schemas one by
one and like wrote a parser that worked
processed like few years of data and
then stopped because well the format
changed so i had to do it again and
again and i finally actually got some
tight device but then it's i found that
there are actually many issues because
for example it the dig done its
disambiguation then you have something
like one entity like name of company
let's say General Electric then like
different lawyers different people
actually inputted into the database
slightly differently one can write
general electric inc one can write GE
one can write General Electric Company
and it's the same stuff but our like
simple partial actually increase it as
something different so this is actually
quite not exactly easy task this
disambiguation so i had to actually look
around what's what's available if there
is anything and i was lucky enough to to
define that there is Gorman funk
Institute for engineering leadership at
university of california berkeley and
they do exactly this and they wrote a
parser that actually does also the
disambiguation and basically data
preparation and i released it as an open
source software it's written in Python 2
and it's available on github so I was
very happy to see this mm-hmm so I can
actually replace my parser with this
much better one and tweak it for my
special use
and well the funk institute actually is
also doing something with the video data
data tape ours they actually really is
the pattern search tool online which is
actually not very online because you
actually you input a query and you give
them your email address and they will
mail you the results few days ago after
maybe some time but it works and they do
lots of descriptive statistics and some
nice displays of the data and it's also
based on the Harvard data versus network
so that's it um the patent data process
flow looks like it is this is actually
this is actually the common funk
Institute process fall I'm using parts
of it definitely you have to collect the
data and into XML format split it into
individual patterns parsed XML fill the
relation database then run to disobey
disambiguation algorithms on the process
data this disambiguation is actually
computationally intensive process so the
code is written in C++ and it takes
quite non-trivial time to run it even on
like smaller data then well from the
prepared data you actually you can run
some statistics on it and you also do
some geocoding and then you consolidate
the data of it or hold big database of
patterns and then the frequency also
provides ipi and some visualizations and
like connections to their online apps so
the schema of the data that I'm actually
using it looks like this well you have
the pattern
in the center and the linkage to the
patent is from all like important parts
that are part of the patent like
assignee application lawyer inventor
references citations and some special
numbers so for example here is the
entity relationship diagram for buttons
with citations claims applications and
classes so this is basically how how the
relational database looks like um yeah
for example yeah you can do lots of
descriptive statistics on this data and
it's exactly what functions does so this
is for example a number of investor
inventors their patent well it seems
like most patents actually have one
inventor and it kind of decreases
exponentially if you are interested if
you you can defense the visit Fung
Institute website and they provide lots
of other information but I will focus on
the semantic analyzes sounding
exploration of the textual data so I do
something called topic modeling I want
to actually replace part of the work of
the of the patent lawyers so the use
case is i have a description of some
invention and i would like to find
semantically similar documents on the
patterns that are already into space so
for that i actually have to build a
topic space of the patents so i compute
the semantic similarity of the documents
and then i will compute actually the
similarity of the new document um
towards the already built space so the
tools i'm using harder and altec a
library which is like the referential
natural language processing to
rule for python and jensen and jensen is
actually the design of jensen is
slightly it's quite different than an l
TK because another TK is more like a
research library that is probably not
that easy to use but Jensen is actually
designed for like her the real world for
like busy people from business and so
it's easy to use it's actually very
efficient optimized and it actually
makes this expression much easier and
the data I'm using our well the
documents are represented as pure text
basically they are consist of abstract
claims and their descriptions
descriptions of the inventions in
buttons so but before we actually start
the semantic analysis we have to do some
text pre-processing in particular
something called the motivation or
stemming and also finding collocations
and named entity recognition so for that
we actually we again we use Jensen and
annul TK so for limit is a shin which is
basically the process of grouping
together different inflected forms of a
word so we can actually analyze them as
a sink single item so it's implemented
in jensen dysfunction limit is that we
run on some well text or document and
that is in natural language and we will
get back a vector of well-known
inflected words so we can actually treat
them three treat all the groups of
different inflected forms as one word
which is quite useful for the
statistical processing and then the
collocations and named entity
recognition
are basically we want to detect
sequences of words that Coke or more
often than food being expected by chance
and also these words often have like
different meaning then they stand
together then when we actually have them
like splitted in like in part because
they are like names of companies or like
parts of phrases so for days we actually
use some statistical analysis of the
text of the sequences and it's nicely
implemented in a nerdy k we find out
trigger arms and big runs so for example
yeah when we have the General Electric
we can treat it as a single token which
has defends the business value and then
we are also want to remove this
so-called stop words which are generic
words such as well six then be too and
yeah we want to remove them because some
of these topic modeling algorithms don't
deal with them really well they actually
got confused so again we use Jensen
because well stop words are present in
jensen and before we yet before we
actually start in the topic modeling
itself you have to deal with the data
data is big and we use something called
data streaming we actually heard
probably quite something about data
streaming and generators iterators
you're so I will repeat it again because
it's actually very useful pattern we can
write this class that actually that
takes one file that is too big to fit
into ram and outputs a generator and we
can actually ask a generator to provide
our data as much as we can actually deal
with
so yeah it's it's implemented like this
in this special case we at the same time
also tokenize the text so we actually
split the text into tokens just output
list of off of words now we can actually
start building the vector space or like
the semantic space so we do something
called vectorization for that we have to
build library dictionary first and the
design is just we have to index text
oaken's by integers because the
algorithms don't deal with the text
strings so well they need integers
basically to index the data so again
using using dictionary in jensen and in
putting our streamed data corpus we
build the ID to word which is our
dictionary so basically it's only its
picturing of words or text text tokens
index by integers then we create a
so-called black back of words vectors
and also like back off word space so
this is this is for this we only need
stream corpus and deterring so let's say
we have this text or document and we
well we tokenize it and this
tokenization well this function actually
out gives us or soda stream of the older
tokens we use the doctor bowl function
on the although the dictionary actually
map it into our backwards
vector space and we do this fit all the
documents then we are processing so we
actually build all the space and then we
finally apply some semantic
transformation zone on this vector space
and well these transformations are
basically some statistical models that
model this natural language and well
basically it only takes one corpus and
outputs another purpose just
transformation we have different choices
to make for example we can choose the
latent semantic indexing or latent
dirichlet allocation or others here i'm
choosing the latent dirichlet allocation
but I played with others some actually
map into like my small place space so
they can be considered as a dimension
time ingenuity reduction sort of but
it's not the case for Latin very high
allocation so again it's nicely
implemented in jensen you just feed it
the corpus choose the number of topics
that you actually want to deal with hear
it from experience it my experience it
doesn't matter how much topics you
actually want because the results are
very similar unless the number of topics
is really small like single digits then
it's actually influencing the results
quite loud but otherwise it doesn't
matter and we also fitted that
dictionary a number of passes and some
parameter alpha which I'm not going to
talk about and then we can actually
print also like the topics and they're
more the most important words for each
topic so for example here week we can
see actually how like the first four
topics look like in this space so they
are basically just too
factor of words it some weights so
actually do topic topic is actually a
probabilistic distribution over the
fixed over the fixed vocabulary and then
you can transform actually new documents
into our space because we need it for
well measuring the distance between the
topics all the documents and so again we
take the text you transform it into the
back of workspace as we've already seen
by tokenizing it and applying the
dictionary function next we transform
text into the LDA space into the topic
space so we've already built the model
so we apply the model on this back home
for vector and we get another vector
that is in our attic space and then we
can for example find the comments most
significant at the a topic by using this
print topic function on the model and um
yeah feeding it the index of the topic
that we find by by finding the maximum
maximum from these significant seas of
these topics into vector and now we
would like to also like evaluate how how
how well it actually how good the model
is but it's quite tricky because the
topic modeling is unsupervised ask so
the best we can actually do probably is
we have to evaluate it on the task we
own to actually model so our goal is to
retrieve semantically similar documents
therefore we actually manually talk
similar documents the group them
together and then compare
what what actually the semantic model
gives us back if it actually can can map
to do comments together or not but this
is this is this is quite resource
intensive I mean human resource
intensive you have to actually well
manually prepare the documents and then
check them so people came out with
different methods that are easier to do
for people for example the vort
intrusion which is basically done like
that when then we have a training topic
we take the first ten words in the topic
like sorted by the significance for the
topic and we substitute substitute one
of them which are dooming chosen word
which is the intruder and then let a
human detect the intruder so this
actually works quite well because people
are quite good at detecting these
intruders if the topic is kind of clear
and we can actually also I completely
avoid the human intervention
intervention to evaluation and and this
metal actually works like this we split
the documents into two parts and then
only check that the topics of the first
half are similar to the topics of the
second half of the same document and
also that the house of different
documents are mostly not similar so as
I've said that because the distribution
over a fixed vocabulary of terms and
this the general idea behind a lot and
very high allocation is too well
statistically model documents as
containing multiple hidden semantic
topics so let's explore the topics in
the big space so here we can see
actually six most significant words of
four random topics and well as you can
see it's actually not very
it doesn't say as much I mean you cannot
it seems like you cannot use it for that
like in your decisions or like your
search because these topics yeah just it
doesn't make that much sense so it seems
like it's much better to actually
measure the topic distance between
different documents and just ignore the
topics so here is the result of running
this topic modeling on this pattern data
and as you can see this this is plot of
topics as they appear in documents and
you can see that there even though there
are many topics well in this case we
chosen like 100 topics each document
contains only on a few of them just most
most documents actually contain between
ten and twenty five topics so it's a
it's a sparse model so we can probably
maybe we could use for measuring this
distance between topics you some well
don't buy functions for syfy functions
for four base beam matrix computations
so let's try to complete a semantic
distance queries by using the distance
or p dysfunction on the matrix of the
topics so if we actually try to compute
the pairwise this paradise paradise
distance of all this data of the these
topics we get memory error because it's
just too big to fit in the memory so
again we have to seek help from Jensen
and the class similarity which does
something called document indexing so it
builds index of our documents based on
their semantic similarity we feed it
our corpus of the stream data and we say
how many features we want basically this
number of features is probably like in
this case it's the number of topics you
want to deal with and this similarity
class splits the index into several
smaller sub-indexes so it scales three
well it's very its memory efficient and
now when we actually computed index the
similarities we can query yeah we can
pray new text and ask for the
similarities or for the most similar
documents into space so again we
vectorize the text into back rewards
then we again transform it into our lda
space and by using the index and telling
you the index how many how many
documents we actually want to see we
query the index for our vector in the LD
X place and we get back two indexes and
well basically the ranking of the of the
of the documents back from the index so
we've actually built the topic space
which we can now ask for for for the
similarities and I would like to just
conclude with some current experiments
that we are running and you would like
to plug in to the to this well search
engine or recommendation engine later
is the new for Jade graph database
because well this buttons actually have
this graph structure that's because the
each pattern actually have some
references and links to other documents
so we could actually take advantage of
it and plug it into graph database and
neo4j for example have as some nice
features of displaying the graph data
into browser so this is definitely
something they are working on and also
elasticsearch we've used a stick search
for indexing our documents and using it
for some done full text search but still
we would like to explore more than what
analytics is possible to do with the
elastic search and how to actually
incorporate more the full text search
and semantic search and the
recommendations so so basically we want
to build the whole recommendation engine
for well improving applications for
patterns and well and then into like
more distant future we could actually
also do the drawings analyzes or the
picture analyzes can actually deploy
some image analyzes algorithms that can
actually recognize very similar real
world innovations and what's actually
interesting is the block chain or the
decentralized protocols for example the
Bitcoin block chain it doesn't have to
be necessary used for for monetary
transactions it can be actually used for
so-called smart contracts you can
actually automatically create contracts
in this public logbook
I'm based on that you can actually
create market that would be ready for
machine use and from that we could
finally create the artificial patent
lawyer hopefully so thank you no no
actually use it basically in the way it
helps me to cluster different documents
into well basically clusters based on on
the similarity of the topics which seem
to be actually more useful because you
get I mean the patent lawyers are
actually forcing these these topics when
they file these patterns according to
some classification but what's actually
useful power seems like to be more
useful is to actually use the
unsupervised algorithms to to classify
the documents according to underline
text so that seemed to be more
yeah in the first instance we have to
cooperate with the lawyers because they
have they have to actually tell us how
they work and what they do so after that
we can replicate them and it's actually
possible that if we actually take it
into extremes the system system actually
might collapse because there might
appear some inconsistencies in how how
the data are actually dealt with so you
can get some contradictions in the
pattern space so i would like to
actually see this if it will progress
as of the beginning you talked about so
on occasions to sever by gravity trying
writers it mostly results you show it
looked like a beauty lounge we're going
out you said a little bit about the
value you found in my ground and very
ground versus universe oh yes you are
right all right yeah I use this like
simple examples and um so all these
tokens were actually single words but in
practice when you deal with this real
world texts that are basically produced
by some companies then these companies
have often well names that are composed
of more than one word so it has actually
real business value with three demos one
entity because it has much more more
significance for this invention or the
document then when we when you actually
split it into like two words that have
some meaning in the natural language but
it's completely different from like the
collocation of the words I said of all
time moving on client problems around
this activation refusing to end this guy
III gamma dash electric electric and GE
and read or email for cyber entities or
they all over to do the same to come
here I mean you are asking more I think
about the process of this emigration so
yeah as I mentioned that's actually done
by the funk Institute there dis mi
greater because yeah i'm actually
already getting the disambiguated data
which is much nicer to deal with then
without you for this reason because you
actually get meaningful well numbers or
statistics when we run the statistics on
the data then it's definitely useful to
treat General Electric as one company
not like the ten ten different companies
and yeah so so it's it's is the steepest
pass code that is on github that you can
check if you are interested
okay so it seems there are no more
questions ah what happens could you do
an analysis articles and see if they
actually isn't relations or methods in
science or science definitely there was
research going on into semantics
exploration of scientific journals or
scientific articles I'm not aware of if
anyone actually try to find correlations
between these scientific articles and
patterns but there are definitely some
obviously but I personally don't know
about this
so any more questions
yes
you